on Prime crime I wondering if
a federal investigation leads to a
sickening Discovery I've seen a lot of
bad stuff for State Attorney this is
especially horrific but as details
emerge the case gets complicated
oh I
I where I was where I am
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases when federal
agents attempt to make a routine arrest
they end up finding something that is
truly unthinkable
I'm wondering if somebody can do a
wellness check
it's just after Christmas 2019 in
Celebration Florida Anthony toad his
wife Megan along with their three
children 13 year old Alec 11 year old
Tyler and four-year-old Zoe haven't been
heard from in weeks I can't seem to get
a hold of them my sister-in-law was
making a comment about and we just kind
of put it all together about
um
things to go to the world ending on the
28th and nobody has talked to them
something to know about Anthony toad
leading up to this disconnect the
physical therapist was actually under
surveillance by federal authorities what
has he wanted for uh Healthcare fraud
Healthcare fraud could be over billing
or billing for services not rendered
basically fraud against Medicare or
Medicaid it seemed pretty clear that he
was in a very bad financial situation he
was trying to
arrange it so as children and wife would
have a lot of enjoyment they moved 15
minutes away from Disney World he spent
a lot of money on a condominium when
that started to unravel
he he knew that he would be viewed as a
failure he was losing control in his
life losing control financially So the
plan was we were going to do some
surveillance get some info take our
photos see if we could find any
information about where this family was
in January 2020 armed with an arrest
warrant deputies moved in on tote
the door we knocked no one came to the
door the door was unlocked so he popped
it open we slowly made our way in he was
at the top of the stairs Tony you coming
downstairs
all right
all right Tony you upstairs
hey come downstairs Bud everything's all
right man just stay calm any children I
can't understand
we asked him where Megan and the
children were he said uh Megan was
upstairs sleeping and he also like
called for her we were getting no answer
what's your wife's name Megan Megan
Maddie
all right come on down Bud we made our
way upstairs to check on on the children
and check on Megan the master bedroom
door was open
there he is what officials find next is
unimaginable
Megan because she was the way her
blanket was and you saw the children
they're all pretty much black the two
boys I just always hair okay
um but yes the two boys are as black as
this leather there's also
a dog so just there may be another
disease
[Music]
Megan Alec Tyler Zoe and the family dog
Breezy are all found dead decomposing in
an upstairs bedroom it was especially
bloody you had people who were drugged
the children were drugged with Benadryl
and then you have some brutal stabbings
what begins as a fraud case suddenly
turns into a horrifying homicide
investigation he lived with the bodies
in the condominium for about three weeks
during that time the according to the
police the smell of decomposition was
extremely pronounced tote is then taken
to the hospital after he appears
disoriented and unstable in fact he said
he had consumed a quantity of Benadryl
pills it's there when he speaks with
police for the very first time tell me
what happened my wife is I like to
quietly ill deliveries and all that kind
of stuff and it was old to be is that
when people die
they go to different aspects and then
sometimes never beat up in the light
energy aspect he talked about how she
started to adopt Eastern religions she
started getting involved in other almost
like Fantastical beliefs like medical
mediums and stuff Friday night we it was
supposed to be a at least a three-step
plan so we all stay together
you know one person separated to the
other the confession well it was a
confession there was a tremendous level
of explanation going on
[Music]
go very uh everybody go very peacefully
we want everybody together okay and that
was my wife swish everybody together he
would say that was essentially all a
dream that he didn't remember any of
that he was in some type of zombie State
he was looking to blame the drugs for
his confession you murdered your three
children
I don't you take full responsibility for
that I don't think really Meg was
involved about people well Megan's dead
but is Anthony Toad the one responsible
for this where we're at right now is a
very sad State all three of your
children are dead I know your wife is
dead I know you're alive unfortunately
[Music]
what are you most upset about damn here
I'm not with my family
in January 2020 Federal authorities show
up to arrest a Connecticut man living
part-time in Florida with his family
over an alleged insurance scam but their
investigation leads them to a revolting
Discovery in the family's rental home
the decomposing bodies of tote's wife
their three young children and the
family dog investigators now need to
make sense of what exactly happened in
that house when Toad is brought in for
questioning a few days later he shares
even more specifics about the killings
watching these videos talking about the
afterlife we started researching and
research and researching and then we
started finding more about the world
just coming to the end the apocalypse
again to avoid this to all go together
all right together all right together
that's correct even though I
accidentally chronically ill for a while
this is really appeal to her maybe the
salvation and everlasting life this was
a guy who had perhaps some delusions but
not enough to make him not understand
the difference between right and wrong
we had sat down and talked with the boys
and Zoe just said what would happen if
mommy died you know how would you feel
what happened with Daddy died what you
feel and because his responses was like
we don't want you to die we want to die
with you according to the police Anthony
used a variety of methods the Benadryl
something came on TV about cloth
medicine
okay so could they have some cough
medicine should I put them to sleep take
over it doesn't cost him just put them
asleep it didn't work and we said we're
just going to have to do some sort of
exact donation
okay completely death first tote goes
into detail about killing four-year-old
Zoe she rolls and starts squiggling and
I put my hand over her mouth and I put a
pillow over top board she started to
fade away I just held that until the
normal motion left it's one thing to
kind of Mumble and answer like oh I
killed somebody it's something else to
give a very detailed explanation of
every single homicide that occurred so
Zoe's gone
and then what happens we're going to
Alex room which is in there just eyeing
each other just
gaining the confidence and stabbed them
and he started kicking
let's try to get up and I reached around
with my hands and held his um nose in
his mouth when it came to 11 year old
Tyler Toth says he and Megan were afraid
their son would Escape I was able to get
in and
get the knife right in there
I got it I got it and it started
bleeding quite a bit he went really
really quick this was especially
horrific and I've seen a lot of bad
stuff as State Attorney but this one you
destroy an entire family we decided that
the dog
well it was by the dog with us and I was
able to hold the not in the
brushed out and her nose
clothes and she went peacefully taupe
then says Megan wanted to die next Meg
why don't you go gave her the knife and
I laid next to her and she put the knife
into her stomach we were laying there
for about 45 minutes after she stabbed
herself
isn't I feel nothing happening so she
decided to do go through her liver she
was stabbed with deep knife wounds
multiple times he was two hands pushed
in she pulled it out she put the knife
right next door
and I just laid with her it seemed like
hours went by and nothing else happening
she goes I want this ended now I want
you to take the pillowcase put it put a
pillow and put it over my head she goes
if you love me you can do this I want to
be with my babies so I said why don't
you take some more Benadryl so he's
you're not gonna fight me
and I'll do it so then it came to me he
was pretty efficient at killing them all
that's what he wanted to achieve and he
did in a pretty straightforward fashion
but when he talked about ending his own
life he couldn't figure out how to do it
we didn't get there until
what Monday what were you doing during
during this time frame we're talking
over two weeks
trying to kill myself I tried the razor
blade zip tie around the neck I was
trying to figure out how to go through
and fall in the mic from the right
direction then I'll honesty I checked
out and powered it out with a knife so
we see kind of a disconnect there
between the methods that are used that
were successful and then these alleged
methods that he used that were not
successful you've upset a lot of people
you guys seem very planned this is very
methodical there was I mean other than
the fact about you taking your own life
which I I'm still kind of questioning I
think the reason Anthony toad initially
confessed is because that's really where
he was
in life at that point I think he had
abandon all hope
you take full take full responsibility
once it's done
okay
if I could commit suicide right now I
would okay well we're not going to let
you do that tote is charged with the
murders of his family and animal cruelty
for allegedly killing the dog but
nothing is as simple as it may seem
coming up what Anthony toad previously
told investigators may not be the real
story
of the story no what happened I know you
know I forgiven her
[Music]
oh
did you guys celebrate Christmas day no
no the kids were dead before Christmas
Connecticut man Anthony tote is charged
with the murder of his family after they
were found dead and decomposing in their
Celebration Florida home in January
2020. from the start of the
investigation tote seemed to be fully
cooperating and telling officials
everything that happened how long would
you say it took to
kill Alec that one I have no idea it
didn't it went quickly but later on Toth
speaks with his sister from jail on
these recorded calls his account is
radically different
foreign
confession I think really hurt him he
tried to work to back away from it
pretty soon after he he made it I don't
remember
we were coming here
I don't see anything after the events
would happen I have no eye where I was
where I am the only thing I remember is
being at the hospital his claim was that
he was kind of out of it he had hit his
head he didn't know what he was doing he
didn't remember the confession tote
tells his sister he wasn't even at home
the night his family was killed that he
was actually at their nearby condo
I am going to tell you this I went over
because Zoe wanted her Mickey silver
necklace for a reason but you'll find
out later I ended up falling asleep
let's just leave it at that okay
I fell asleep for him I was supposed to
wake up at 11 11 30 and didn't wake up
the next morning
I have no idea
installed investigators because I was
completely stowed I was asleep
he supposedly came home to his dead
children and his wife who was trying to
commit suicide I miss you guys
tremendously
when investigators first looked into the
Anthony toe case they believed 100 that
he was guilty but of course they had to
investigate all aspects one of those was
that Megan had killed their three
children and then had discussion with
him hurt herself and then killed herself
with a knife
so that leaves this this possibility
that Megan was the Killer and committed
suicide love is blinds at times
when things happen
that you're not expecting these aren't
things that we should talk about now
just know
there again his narrative was that she
essentially lost her mind
and he was trying to support her during
that time and he still wanted to protect
her even in death he wanted to defend
her reputation
those that know you just want to
understand now let me hear some Horrors
I really do that's funny
it's pretty unusual for a mother to kill
her children it does happen and there
have been really famous notorious cases
where it's happened I say goodbye to
them yet so first the first thing I'm
doing here I'm at peace with what
happened and I'm ready to tell the world
my story tell the story what happened
and to go home up next who really killed
Megan Alec Tyler Zoe and Breezy she was
trying to explain to me what she did
trying to
make me understand
[Music]
together
after authorities find the dead bodies
of Anthony toth's wife Megan three
children Alec Tyler and Zoe and family
dog Breezy in their Florida home the
former physical therapist is arrested
and charged with murder and animal
cruelty tote would initially confess to
the killings but then in recorded
Jailhouse phone calls with his sister he
claimed he wasn't the killer but rather
it was Megan everything really changed
to make Netflix
really the whole situation over and over
again in April of 2022 it would be up to
a jury to sort out the truth as Anthony
Toad's criminal trial began
you're gonna be informed by the
defendant in his interview
that he is the one that took the lives
of Megan tote Alexander Tyler tote and
Zoe toe Toad's defense presented one
sole witness Anthony toad himself
came home and my kids were dead it was
the most horrible day of my life
you know what I mean what horrible is
my wife
died in front of me almost
did you kill yourself
oh
if you put it all on the wife the wife's
not there to rebut it and that can work
sometimes if you can portray the victim
in a negative light I didn't even see
this coming
they say you know blindsided this is a
Blind Side by like a Mack truck with
filled with dynamite tote then face
cross-examination by the prosecution you
told detectives that you went into Zoe's
room gathered the courage and you rolled
over on top of your daughter until she
suffocated isn't that what you told law
enforcement is this a yes or no question
did you want the answer yes or no
question that is what the video yes
showed you and your testimony here today
is that Megan did it
Megan
killed Sophie he kept using that phrase
that's what the video says that's what
the video shows as if it was some type
of alternate universe you told law
enforcement yeah
Tyler was fast and he was you saw the
video and you saw the video also of
saying I said things that have been
proven incorrect
that's not responsive to my question
actually is yes I don't remember
anything after I left the house until I
got to jail well that is you in the
video right it's a sickly version of me
yes thank God I don't tell you I
assassinate again where the Benadryl
comes in and it's mental health issues
it could try to convince a jury that he
did not know what he was saying when he
was confessing you told law enforcement
on multiple occasions that you went into
Alex room and you stabbed Alec and you
suffocated out isn't that correct that's
partially correct and your testimony
today is that that is not true my
testimony today
is the fact that Megan killed her kids
and killed herself but was the jury
convinced after deliberating for just
over six hours they returned their
verdict State of Florida versus Anthony
John Tote we the jury finally defend
them guilty of first-degree murder as
charged in the indictment we the jury
find the defendant guilty of cruelty to
animals Anthony toad was convicted
across the board I think they could have
made an okay argument that it was
possible that Megan was the Killer
but there was no way to get around that
confession no matter what they said when
that confession came in that was the end
of it his whole defense is undermined by
the fact
that he stayed with the dead bodies this
guy had the means motive and opportunity
he was desperate financially he was
acting irrationally and he committed
this horrific crime and then tried to
cover it up just before toad is
sentenced he addresses the court one
last time this was a personal
catastrophe in everybody's life in my
family including myself
I maintain my innocence I love my wife
I love my children I was not there the
night my children died I think this
speaks to that whole kind of pressured
speech vibe that Anthony gives off he
demands that people listen to him he
can't comprehend that they wouldn't
believe his lies you know maybe it's
just this last chance of getting
attention
I'm sorry I did not do this to profess
as innocent until the end it just adds
insult to injury here's a guy who press
believes his own lies or it's just a
such a megalomaniac that thinks he could
talk his way out of it a jury has
unanimously determined after listening
to the evidence presented that you
Anthony John toad are a destroyer of
worlds your sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole this
is a way of exerting what little control
he had left in the world and that's why
the judge said you're a destroyer of
worlds that was the only Power he had
left to destroy others worlds and he did
but now he's got to pay the price
the Anthony toad case presented a lot of
questions in terms of how these heinous
crimes were committed and when and where
but looking back on all of the
conflicting statements we never really
got an answer as to the why
and unfortunately that is a question
that may never be answered that's all we
have for you here on Prime crime as
always thank you for joining us and
until next time stay safe
[Music]
foreign